Texas governor Greg Abbott joins me now
anything you want to say to Raditz
so listen it's just crazy to suggest
anything like that but you know it
really is telling Jesse because it shows
that the mainstream media they they're
really clueless about what's going on in
the Border as well as Joe Biden's
spokesperson who said that the border is
not open we can prove this actually with
this very important piece of information
and that it was just two and a half
years ago when we had the most secure
Border in decades under President Trump
doing four things romantic Mexico title
42 in Catch and Release and build the
border wall that's what president Trump
did and we had the lowest border
crossings since last century now under
Joe Biden we have far more
record-setting numbers of people coming
across the border than ever before is
all because of Joe Biden's policies did
you want to fly Raditz up in the air in
that little helicopter behind you guys
and show her what was actually going
down
Jesse we did right after that interview
shortly after that question we did fire
up in the helicopter and showed her
exactly what was going on in the ground
and the fact of the matter is there are
people coming across the border and Joe
Biden's doing nothing about it and
that's exactly why Texas is having to
step up and take extraordinary efforts
that have never been undertaken by any
state in the history of the United
States to try to secure our border right
now we're looking at images of looking
at like dozens and dozens of illegal
immigrants sleeping in sleeping bags
pillows comforters in the El Paso
Airport have you seen this
so and Jesse this is an important one
I'm about to tell you and that is one
aspect about all those people that you
see sleeping there as you were kind of
alluding to in your commentary earlier
they've already been given a piece of
paper authorizing them to be there in
that airport or in the United States so
they got the free pass once they got to
a border patrol agent who gave them that
pass
all right and is this one of these
things like oh go find a nice Center in
a year and I'll see you never because
this is what's happening are you going
to continue to send illegal immigrants
through bus or playing two cities in the
Northeast
so Jesse let me tell you how it works
and that is the first thing we try to do
is to send people back or to return them
or repel them that's our first line of
defense the second line of defense is to
arrest them but the cartels know this
the reason why you see people streaming
across the border in single file going
to a particular location is because the
cartels know to take them to that
location because the federal government
is on that location and the federal
government will controlling process
these people give them their paperwork
and set them free it's those people who
are set free that we put on buses and
send to Sanctuary cities across the
country and yes more are in route
tonight and we will continue to send
them okay well Aspen is a it's a great
place this time of year for anybody who
likes The Great Outdoors thank you so
much Governor hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now